appreciate it great thighs good chest
hair
nice face and uh great
stash we got three shows in the park
uh this is the first one they're all in
central park so we're gonna do this one
we're gonna run to the other one on 79th
and whatever then we're gonna do that
one and come back and close the
third one out which is back here this is
comedy now it's in a park there's no
microphone you're basically just a hobo
screaming to strangers uh in the park
all right here we go comedy all right
where do we begin i mean we got to
address uh the elephant and the anal
corona it's a it's a [ __ ] we are we're
all sick of it that's why we're here
you know corona it's been so long it
feels like the check engine light you
know at first you're scared of it then
after a while you're like [ __ ] it i
gotta go to work
i hate it i can't believe this whole
thing started because some guy [ __ ] a
bat
um i feel like a like a woman in a
ranged marriage
you know i i didn't choose this i got to
cover my face and if i say my opinion i
get yelled at
all right i can't tell if i'm bombing or
if in the park
we'll say both that was brutal i mean
hey you're outdoors you have no
microphone
there's no ceiling there's music that
was brutal that was the first one
my ego is through the floor let's go to
the other one
yeah this is this is comedy now folks
it's uh pretty depressing
that's what we have to offer a lot of
skin
i think we're a little we might be a
little early too ah it starts at 10
minutes we're perfect
hey career low point
i don't know anything i don't watch the
news uh i did hear r kelly got a he got
interviewed and he said a coveted 19
tool for me
that's for you guys all right there you
go we're getting there
this crowd's like anal takes a minute
eventually it'll feel good that's what
my stepdad told me
oh that's my stepdad whoo
that is a miscarriage on wheels holy
hell
[Music]
my god that was that was appalling
good luck i don't even blame them you
know it's just not the right setting
oh man one more one more i think they
were looking for more of a positive spin
ah well this is comedy comedy's not
positive
unlike corona
i hope on the next show i get one laugh
uh do we need this for parking this one
is uh so hopefully one day i get to open
for nick cannon
let's go do that last show
[Music]
hey thank you i'm gonna be a lot darker
than the other guys
this is a great gig next week i'm doing
a target minneapolis so
i can't complain yeah black people got
hit really hard by covid which shocks me
because they usually handle illness so
well they're strong people i mean look
at magic johnson he's still going
right hell he beat coby
ah that joke uh like him didn't land
oh words all right this [ __ ] kills at a
comedy club
uh but you guys are nice you know a
little square but you're all right you
know some comedians out there hate woke
people
i mean none more than cosby thanks a lot
i'm kevin hart have a good night thank
you
ah last show of the night we got three
in and one park
that's gotta be a record three shows at
one park i mean aside from a crazy hobo
that's i think we set a new precedent
yelling at strangers
no microphone everything was against us
i stepped on a heroin needle i have aids
but comedy lives we got to keep doing it
we got to keep going you got to make it
work
i hate myself i'll see you in hell kanye
2020.
you